[Musik]
Bianca stritt mit ihrem Freund dann war
sie weg
Bianca Blömeke vor zwölf Jahren spurlos
verschwunden was ist mit Bianca passiert
ist sie weggelaufen oder wurde sie Opfer
eines Verbrechens
[Musik]
was hat es mit den Blutspuren aus
Biancas Badewanne auf sich und was kann
nach 21 Jahren dieser Schrubber zur
Aufklärung beitragen
unser Cold Case heute der wirft wirklich
eine Menge Fragen auf am 6 August 2000
da streitet Bianca Blömeke mit ihrem
Freund Sven l Nachbarn die hören das
Geschreie das Gekreische und dann
plötzlich Stille nichts mehr aber
niemand ruft an diesem 6 August die
Polizei und Bianca Blömeke die ist die
Zeit diesem sechsten August spurlos
verschwunden ohne ihr Geld ohne ihr
Handy und vor allem ohne Ihr Baby unsere
Reporterin Katrin voice da die begleitet
diesen Fall von Anfang an und die hat
jetzt mit der Mutter von Bianca Blömeke
gesprochen
jeden Tag blickt Erika Schneider in
Essen von ihrem Balkon auf die Wohnung
aus der ihre Tochter Bianca vor 21
Jahren verschwand
[Musik]
das ist natürlich ganz schwer wenn wenn
Geburtstage sind oder Hochzeiten
gehe ich natürlich mit Bianca nicht mehr
leben kann
bianca hat eine glückliche Kindheit und
weiß schon als Teenagerin dass sie früh
Mutter werden möchte mit 18 Jahren lernt
Sie Sven l kennen im Januar 2000 bringt
sie ihren gemeinsamen Sohn zur Welt doch
der lernt seine Mutter nie kennen wächst
bei einer Pflegefamilie auf denn am 6
August 2000 verschwindet Bianca bis
heute spurlos hat Vater Sven etwas damit
zu tun
seit Biancas verschwinden berichtet
bild-reporterin Katrin woister immer
wieder über den Fall
süßer Fratz hoffentlich ist deine Mama
einfach nur weggelaufen
Bianca stritt mit ihrem Freund dann war
sie weg
Bianca Blömeke vor zwölf Jahren spurlos
verschwunden
als wir bei diesem ersten Termin bei den
Eltern waren und die Suche anlief
hat auch der Ex-Freund der Vermissten
noch vehement mitgesucht hat sich mit
Flugblättern fotografieren lassen das
hat sich dann geändert als er
zwischenzeitlich in den Wochen und
Monaten danach von der Polizei auch als
Verdächtiger geführt wurde was ist mit
Bianca passiert ist sie weggelaufen oder
wurde sie Opfer eines Verbrechens
[Musik]
was hat es mit den Blutspuren aus
Biancas Badewanne auf sich und was kann
nach 21 Jahren dieser Schrubber zur
Aufklärung beitragen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bei der Vermisstenfall von Bianca gehen
wir mittlerweile auch von tötungsweg aus
bei Tötungsdelikten kann halt jeder
Hinweis jedes kleine Puzzlestück für uns
relevant sein
paar blömecke ist einer der
ekelhaftesten Fälle Deutschlands Erika
Schneider Biancas Mutter will endlich
Gewissheit was mit ihrer Tochter
passiert ist
Essen Vogelheim 5 km nördlich der City
in diesem Mehrfamilienhaus wohnt Bianca
Blömeke im Jahr 2000 mit ihrem Sohn bis
zu dem Tag an dem sie verschwindet von
Sven L ist sie frisch getrennt
ich stehe hier vor dem Haus in dem Erika
Schneider die Mutter der Vermissten
Bianca Blömeke wohnt Frau Schneider ist
genau hierher gezogen weil keine 100
Meter entfernt man sieht es dort drüben
das Haus ist in dem Bianca zuletzt
gewohnt hat aus diesem Haus ist sie am
6.8.2000 verschwunden durch den direkten
Blick auf Biancas alte Wohnung fühlt
sich Erika Schneider ihrer Tochter ein
Stückchen näher mit Sven dem Vater ihres
Kindes hatte Bianca oft Streit
ich würde mal so abschätzen dass sie so
anderthalb Jahre bis zwei Jahre zusammen
waren
wobei sie ja im Dezember 99 schon
ausgezogen ist weil er hier in dem Bauch
getreten hat wieso hochschwanger war gab
es am 6 August 2000 einen Streit der
tödlich endete die Beziehung zwischen
Bianca und Sven war schwierig doch trotz
der Übergriffe und der Trennung blieb
Bianca immer in Verbindung zum Vater
ihres Kindes
bianca hat aber trotzdem Kontakt zu ihm
aufrecht erhalten weil sie wollte dass
Ihr Kind Kontakt zum Vater hat weil sie
selbst hat sehr darunter gelitten dass
ihr kein ihr Vater keinen Kontakt wollte
und er hat natürlich dann auch auf das
Kind aufgepasst wenn sie bei mir
geändert hat
unweites Fußballstadions von Rot-Weiß
Essen betreibt Erika im August 2000 eine
Kneipe wo ihr Bianca am 5.8 bis 5 Uhr
morgens aushilft sie lernt einen jungen
Mann kennen mit dem sie das Lokal
verlässt dort sieht Erika ihre Tochter
zum letzten Mal Biancas Kleidung aus
jener Nacht hat sie aufbewahrt wenn Sie
das so anfassen sind sie dann zurück bei
dieser Nacht vor 21 Jahren als sie mit
Ihnen zusammen in der Gaststätte
gekellnert hat ich sehe sie dann auch
immer noch vor mir in der Kneipe und wie
sie dann nachher im Taxi gesessen hat
und wir können noch gesagt habe ich lieb
dich und pass auf dich auf und sie sagte
auch Mama ich lieb dich am nächsten
Morgen werden Bianca und ihr Ex-Freund
Sven l von Nachbarn gesehen wie sie
zusammen in die Wohnung gehen es kommt
wieder zum Streit etwa aus Eifersucht am
Nachmittag telefoniert Erika zum letzten
Mal mit ihrer Tochter
ja ich habe dann noch mal mit ihr so
gegen 14:45 Uhr telefoniert Tarif Sie
mich an und sagte ich sage alles in
Ordnung ja sagt Mama der ich sag dem
jetzt der braucht gar nicht mehr
wiederkommen ich will den gar nicht mehr
sehen ich gehe jetzt in der Wanne
eine Stunde später versucht Erika ihre
Tochter erneut zu erreichen aber Sven
geht ans Telefon immer wieder ruft Erika
an jedes Mal hört sie etwas anderes
warum geht Bianca nicht ans Telefon das
war sehr untypisch aber das ist mir in
dem Moment gar nicht aufgefallen weil er
mir sagte ja sie sind Wanne oder sie ist
mit dem Kind beschäftigt
oder sie ist eine gute Zigaretten holen
vom Gefühl her sage ich so wenn ich im
Nachhinein wenn ich mich rein spüre kam
mir das schon komisch vor aber mein Kopf
wollte es nicht realisieren um 16 Uhr 30
bringt Sven das Kind zu Oma Hedwig
Schneider er erzählt dass Bianca und ihr
Streit hätten und sich in Ruhe
aussprechen müssten kurze Zeit später
holt Sven l das Kind wieder ab und
erklärt Bianca sei nicht mehr in die
Wohnung zurückgekehrt
meine Mutter ist dann den Sonntag gegen
Abend ist er dann rüber im Biancas
Wohnung und weil er da gehaust hat und
an dem Wochenende hat sie dann gespült
und hat auch das Badezimmer bisschen
sauber gemacht und meine Mutter hat dann
Blut in der Wanne gefunden und hat sich
aber gedacht die hat ihre Regel gehabt
und hat es nicht weggemacht eine
mögliche Spur wird vernichtet war es
Menstruationsblut oder Blut einer
Verletzung
und Bianca hat auch Flurwoche dann hat
sie ihm noch einmal Wasser gemacht mit
Putzzeug hat ihm den draußen vor der Tür
hingestellt und hat gesagt hier den Flur
putzt du jetzt und da war er schon so
nervös dass er den einmal umgestoßen hat
hatte Sven etwas zu verbergen und meine
Mutter sagte er hat sich auf dem
Fensterbank hat er gesessen hat auf die
Straße geschaut und hat immer gesagt
jetzt ist er schon wieder hier
vorbeigefahren die bianca hat aber weder
Führerschein nach Auto
[Musik]
also alles sehr mysteriös um 23 Uhr ruft
Erika das letzte Mal an wieder behauptet
Sven Bianca sei nicht nach Hause
gekommen als Erika in die Wohnung kommt
findet sie aber Geldbeutel Schlüssel und
Handy der verschwundenen nur ihr Ausweis
fehlt 24 Stunden später startet Erika
nun eine Suchaktion doch Bianca bleibt
verschwunden nach vier Tagen Suche gibt
Erika eine Vermisstenanzeige auf ihr
Eindruck die Polizei handelt zu
zögerlich bin dann zu vermiesten Stelle
hin wollten Vermisstenanzeige aufgeben
und die Dame hat mich dann aber
regelrecht ausgelacht und hat gesagt
19-Jährige verschwindet schon mal ich
kenne noch mein Kind
und ist dann auch unter auch unter Zwang
sind sie dann mit mir in Biancas Wohnung
gegangen doch die Durchsuchung der
Wohnung bleibt ergebnislos und erst
Wochen später berichten Nachbarn
gegenüber Erikas Mutter von einem
heftigen Streit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
oben drüber die Nachbarn
die haben auch einen Knall gehört und
dann war Ruhe haben aber ganz lange Zeit
nichts gesagt das ist dann erst durch
Zufall rausgekommen was ich dann dann
später bei der Polizei angegeben habe
und die wurden dann wohl auch verhört
die neue Aussage der Nachbarn
die Blutspur in der Wanne und die
Tatsache dass Bianca verschwunden ist
ohne etwas mitzunehmen verändert die
Situation für die Polizei die
Ermittlungen werden intensiviert
[Musik]
das denn wissenski ist Ermittler bei der
Polizei Essen er rollt den Fall Bianca
Blömeke wieder auf seine Vorgänger
errichten erst Ende Oktober 2000 die von
Erika gewünschte Mordkommission zu spät
gute zwei drei Monate nach dem
Verschwinden vom Bianca da wo die
Mordkommission eingerichtet und dann
sind auch Durchsuchungsaktionen
gestartet und und auch der die Wohnung
holt sich angeschaut das waren so
unterschiedlichen Gründe das alles ja
die nicht optimal gelaufen sind das
macht dann das Ermitteln also wesentlich
schwieriger
hat Sven seiner Ex-Freundin Bianca etwas
angetan die Polizei hört Svens Handy ab
und sucht nach möglichen
leichenablageorten auch das ufer-gelände
am Rhein herne-kanal wo Bianca und Sven
häufig waren wird abgesucht Erika
Schneider war dort oft mit Bianca
spazieren heute geht sie die Strecke mit
Reporterin Katrin woister ab
manchmal setze ich mich einfach nur hin
und lässt und manchmal sieht sich
einfach nur hier und
sehe dann Bianca im Wasser das ist der
Ort wo sie vielleicht genau dort auch
gesessen hat mit ihnen genau auf diesem
Stück Gras auf diesen Steinen haben sie
das zusammen erlebt ja und jetzt fehlt
Ihnen dieses das fehlt natürlich und das
21 Jahre lang ne die Suchaktion am Ufer
und im Wasser ist seinerzeit erfolglos
trotzdem kommt es am 2 mai 2001 aufgrund
der Aussage der Nachbarn zur Festnahme
von Biancas Ex-Freund Sven l er gilt als
Hauptverdächtiger und wird bei der
Polizei vernommen doch die Beweise gegen
ihn reichen nicht aus er kommt
schließlich auf freien Fuß
die Spuren führen ins Nichts der Fall
Bianca Blömeke wird zum codecase
Bianca Sohn justin ist mittlerweile 21
zuerst wächst der bei seinem Vater auf
kommt aber dann in eine Pflegefamilie
obwohl Erika Schneider den Kontakt zu
ihrem Enkel sucht kommt es nur zu
einzelnen Treffen alles was ihr bleibt
ist die Erinnerung an ihre Tochter es
ist natürlich ganz schwer wenn wenn
Geburtstage sind oder Hochzeiten
gehe ich natürlich mit Bianca nicht mehr
leben kann
ich möchte Bianca nur noch finden
dass ich so begraben kann und das war
dann auch anfangen können so trauern
weil auch das konnten wir die ganzen
Jahre nicht aber mit der Suche
beschäftigt sind aber ich bin so in so
einem Schwebezustand
ein Prozent sagt ja vielleicht doch noch
lebt sie und der andere sagt nee ist
unmöglich sie muss tot sein
die Polizei sucht auch heute 21 Jahre
später noch nach Zeugen wer hat am 6
August 2000 etwas beobachtet an Biancas
Wohnung in der Vogelheimer Straße 114
oder in der Wohnung wo es wenn bei
seinem Vater wohnte ein paar Häuser
weiter oder am Rhein-Herne-Kanal wo sie
sich gerne aufhielten wer kann zu
Biancas verschwinden etwas aussagen
der Ermittler das denn Wisnewski wertet
sämtliche damals gesicherten Gegenstände
des cold cases noch einmal neu aus
[Musik]
im Jahre 2000 war ja auch schon die
DNA-Analyse möglich aber heute kann man
viel feiner viel besser suchen man hat
viel bessere wissenschaftliche Methoden
um mit denen herauszufinden
von der Analyse dieses Schrubbers in
einem Speziallabor erhofft sich der
Ermittler neue Erkenntnisse über die Tat
es geht um
Blut man kann nämlich auch feststellen
mittlerweile
woher die DNA aus dem Körper stammt dass
die sogenannte rna-untersuchung
und das ist jetzt hier in dem Fall quasi
auch angewendet worden die Ermittler
wollen wissen
bei menstr
uation brauchbare Hinweise ergibt die
Analyse nicht zudem werden die Ermittler
auf einen speziellen Spürhund aufmerksam
flintstone seine Fähigkeiten sind
europaweit gefragt Anfang des Jahres
wird er auf einem Essen erbrachtgeländer
eingesetzt
blindstorm ist ein archäologie-hund das
heißt der ist darauf spezialisiert die
Nekropolen zu finden also die
Bestattungen und das macht der insofern
weil er die die Knochen riechen kann 14
Meter tief reicht sein Spürsinn wird er
fündig legt er sich auf den Boden und
bellt flintstone hat schon 17 Mordfälle
aufgedeckt im Fall bianca wurde er
allerdings nicht fündig noch nicht
trotz sind wir auch in der Überlegung
den Hund nach wie vor weiter einzusetzen
um da mögliche ja Örtlichkeiten
abzusuchen ja und den Ableger Ablageort
dann zu finden
Totschlag verjährt nach 20 Jahren daher
könnten mögliche Mitwisser heute eine
Auskunft geben ohne strafrechtlich
verfolgt zu werden darauf hofft der
Ermittler
vielleicht hat sich auch der Täter einen
anderen Menschen gegenüber offenbart und
die Person die suchen wir also die
mitwässer die Hinweise geben könnten was
mit Bianca damals geschehen ist
Erika Schneider konnte mit Hilfe von
Spendengeldern eines Vereins eine
Belohnung in Höhe von 3.600 Euro
ausloben für Hinweise die zu Bianca
führen
keiner braucht heute Angst mehr haben
von der Beurteilung egal was passiert
ist bitte sag mir wo bianca ist
denn
ich bin ich bin auch nicht mehr
ja zornig oder wütend auf dich die
Zeiten sind vorbei ich möchte nur Bianca
finden damit ich und meine Familie
abschließen können mit der Suche
wer kann etwas Sachdienliches zur
Aufklärung beitragen helfen sie den Fall
Bianca Blömeke endlich aufzuklären
Hinweise an das Polizeipräsidium Essen
unter 02018290
[Musik]
und wir haben es gerade gesehen viele
Indizien haben damals Biancas Freund
Sven l in den Fokus der Ermittler
gerückt er verstrickte sich in
Widersprüche und saß damals sogar ein
paar Tage in U-Haft aber zu einer
Anklage ist es nie gekommen keine
Beweise keine Leiche und kein Prozess
aber natürlich hat uns ja alle
interessiert was er nach all den Jahren
über den Fall denkt und unsere porterin
die hat Sven l noch mal aufgespürt ja
und seine Reaktion auf unsere Kamera die
hat uns ja alle wirklich überrascht
[Applaus]
dürfen wir sie mal kurz was fragen
ja kein Wort nur einen Schlag auf unsere
Kamera eingefangen hat dieses Szene
unsere porterin Katrin voice da die uns
jetzt zugeschaltet ist hallo guten Abend
Katrin
guten Abend und sag uns einmal wie hast
du diesen Moment erlebt mit Sven L
ja ich wusste auch nicht genau was auf
mich zukommt da ich ja auch ihn in den
letzten 20 Jahren nicht gesehen hatte
und in dem Moment wirkt er auf mich
einfach nur sehr entschlossen das ging
alles sehr schnell in der Sequenz sieht
man ja auch dass er keinen Moment zögert
mit seiner Reaktion ich hatte auch nicht
den Eindruck dass es für ihn einen
Moment des Nachdenkens des der
Überlegung gab ob es vielleicht eine
Option sein könnte mit uns ein Gespräch
zu führen das war also nicht der Fall
gleichzeitig war er sehr kontrolliert
geht er regt sich nicht auf er jagt uns
nicht weg er greift nach der Kamera und
geht dann ganz entspannt weiter zum Haus
durch und es verschwunden das war so
mein Eindruck in der Sekunde Katrin ich
habe es gesagt du begleitest diesen Fall
ja wirklich von Anfang an warum war es
jetzt so wichtig für dich noch mal mit
Sven l zu sprechen
für mich war der wesentliche Grund
natürlich dass wenn L nachweislich der
letzte Mensch ist von dem wir wissen
dass er Bianca lebend gesehen hat
natürlich hätte ich gerne gehört wie war
sie in dem Moment wie ist sie im
vorgekommen was könnte seine Theorie für
das Verschwinden sein das hätte ich
Ihnen gerne gefragt und ich hätte ihn
auch gerne gefragt wie er das seinem
Sohn all die Jahre vielleicht auch
vermittelt hat diese Mutter die nicht
mehr da ist das Kind war wenige Monate
alt das wären die vordringlichen Fragen
gewesen die ich ihm gestellt hätte
Katrin zum Abschluss einmal könnte aber
auch alles ganz anders sein könnte es
auch ein völlig anderen Täter geben der
etwas mit dem Verschwinden von Bianca zu
tun hat
ja selbstverständlich klares Ja wir
haben ja auch den Ermittler den Herrn
Wisnewski gehört es gibt keine Leiche es
gibt seit August 2000 keinen anderen
bekannten Aufenthaltsort der Bianca
Blömeke es gibt keine ausreichenden
belastenden Spuren für den damaligen
Hauptverdächtigen es könnte jedes
Szenario letztendlich möglich sein wir
wissen es eben nicht und genau das ist
ja auch der Grund weshalb die Polizei
Essen jetzt diese Anstrengung noch mal
unternimmt um jeder Spur nachzugehen und
vielleicht auch völlig neue
Ermittlungsansätze zu gewinnen und
Katrin du bleibst für uns an diesem Fall
dran vielen vielen Dank für deine
Recherchen und alles Gute
danke
ja es ist wirklich ein Fall der ans Herz
geht seit 21 Jahren da hofft die Familie
von Bianca Blömeke darauf dass der Fall
endlich aufgeklärt wird wenn sie doch
noch etwas wissen was eben das Leid von
Biancas Familie endlich beenden kann
dann melden Sie sich bei der Polizei
Essen unter 02018290
[Musik]